I hope the coffee flavor is strong
enough I don't think it's gonna work
when you fry it Moment of Truth
[Music]
my name is Gideon and you might know me
for me from Tick Tock making Filipino
food fried chicken or really anything
crispy and today I have a very special
guest with me tick tock's heartthrob
Owen Han hello I'm Owen Han I'm a food
content creator and I specialize in
sandwiches so Gideon is the crispy King
and I'm gonna put him to the test
I'm going to challenge you to take a
non-crispy dish and make it crispy all
right Owen what'd you bring me so here
we have
a classic tiramisu this is my favorite
dish I'm not a sweets guy but if I see
this on the menu I'm getting it every
time tiramisu literally translates to
pick me up so it's like a dish that's
supposed to you know make you feel good
it's light it's got coffee mascarpone
but the thing it's lacking is texture
and that's where you come in think you
can do it I think I got a few tricks but
uh we'll see what I can do let's break
down the tiramisu well tiramisu is a
really popular sweet creamy and coffee
flavored dessert which typically starts
with a layer of coffee or espresso soap
ladyfingers and then on top of that a
layer of lightly sweetened whipped cream
and mascarpone and invested with cocoa
powder traditionally we soak ladyfingers
in coffee but obviously that's going to
be soggy right so I saw this thing on
Tick Tock where you can make a rice chip
but instead of using water we're gonna
use coffee to have that flavor and keep
that crisp all right so first things
first we're gonna rinse the rice to get
rid of that extra starch now our rice is
washed now we're gonna add the coffee
and we're gonna bring this to a boil and
once it boils we're going to simmer it
for about an hour you just really want
to overcook the rice so it's easier to
blend later because we're going to make
paste okay it's been an hour and as you
can see the coffee has been absorbed by
the rice and it's very overcooked it's
very soft usually you really don't want
to serve rice like this but for this
recipe this is what you need we're gonna
blend the overcooked rice even though it
looks really weird but you got to trust
the process you're just looking for a
really smooth consistency
okay this looks great it looks like a
very loose peanut butter but that's what
you're looking for because we're going
to spread it nice and thin on a baking
sheet now I'm going to spread the paste
that we made the coffee rice paste so we
can put in the dehydrator I hope the
coffee flavor is strong enough so we can
taste it in the dish but I also hope
it's not too strong that it overpowers
the entire thing you want it thin
because if it's too thick it takes too
long to dehydrate so just try your best
to keep it even okay so now I'm gonna
scoop the rest and we'll be right back
and now we're gonna dehydrate it with
our handy dandy dehydrator a dehydrator
is pretty much just like a gentle oven
it goes lower than a usual oven and it's
more precise and accurate if you don't
have this you can also use an oven okay
so we are going to dehydrate this for
about two hours or until it looks like a
fruit roll-up now we're making the
tiramisu cream I'm Gonna Keep It
traditional we have egg yolks and a
double boiler you're gonna add your
sugar you want to gently cook the eggs
without turning into scrambled eggs and
you also don't want to serve raw eggs
you know now that it's pale and triple
in volume I can tell that it's ready to
go and now we're going to add our
mascarpone cream foreign
just folding the mascarpone in the egg
yolk mixture
our mascarpone and egg yolk mixture is
nice smooth and silky it's time to make
the whipped cream I asked for an
electric mixer because I got really
tired from the last one so you want to
mix just the cream until it's nice and
frothy then we add the sugar you want to
whip it into like a soft Peak because
we're gonna fold it in the mascarpone
egg yolk mixture so we're going to add a
third of the whipped cream at a time so
we can slowly get that texture that we
want we want it nice and Airy and just
incorporate as much air as you can all
right I'm happy with this we're gonna
let this chill and let's move on to my
favorite part which is frying
okay so this is the coffee rice leather
that we've been working on this came out
perfect so it's still flexible it's like
a fruit roll up and it should puff up
when we fry it so we're gonna cut this
in smaller pieces so when we fry it we
can stack it at the end it doesn't have
to be perfect because when we fry it
it's just gonna curl up moment of truth
if I did this correctly it should puff
up the moment it touches the oil all
right here we go
[Music]
I'm hearing the right sounds
now we have our coffee rice chip
pretty happy with that okay so this is
exactly what I was looking for nice and
crispy
thank god it worked now it's time for
assembly which is my favorite part
because it's the easiest and we get to
eat after we have the mascarpone
component and we have the ladyfinger
component which is now a coffee rice
chip I'm just gonna put like a little
dollop of cream to act as a paste so
that the the chip doesn't slide and
we're gonna layer it with the cream
all right we're gonna dust it with a
cocoa powder and just for that little
dramatic effect shave chocolate there we
have it I'm pretty happy with this oh
and better like this or else I'm turning
him crispy let's see what he thinks
all right Gideon let's see what we got I
tried my best and hopefully you like it
this is nuts first looks it's like crazy
like in a great way very cool the like
chip layer we got going on here reminds
me of chicharron so I think what we got
here is gonna be crispy let's just give
it a little sound check
all right I think we're just going to go
in with our hands this looks very sturdy
look at that I've never been able to
hold a Tiramisu in my hands like this
all right we're just gonna go for a big
bite big bite
no I want one for it wow let me try them
I think you just bit my finger a little
bit but that's cool that one's crispy
you nailed the mascarpone cream that
just really resembles a classic tiramisu
had the hint of cocoa I will say the one
thing it's kind of lacking
coffee flavor that was what I was
thinking earlier I thought it was enough
I didn't get any sort of hint of coffee
which some people argue they don't like
tiramisu because of that I personally do
yeah I think creatively it's like a 10
out of 10. also like I'm eating with my
hands it was a lot of fun if you guys
just rewind and listen to that bite
you think I still hold the title of the
crispy King I think it would be a
dishonor if I didn't call you the crispy
king after that so you are for sure
still the Krispy kid yeah that's right
I'm just glad you liked it man dude that
was so sweet thank you all right guys
thank you for watching if you have any
foods that you want me to crispy five
leave it in the comments below and we'll
see you next time bye
[Music]
thank you